I'll tell you a quick story about what
happens next but I'll tell you when I
teach the very first class I always say
and I make this statistic up depending
on how I'm feeling the room I will say
98% of you will fail and people go oh
and I say you'll fail because you'll
never finish you will never finish your
script and and sad that true I'm not
wrong I'm pretty darn close and I'm
taught hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of students at this point and
not finishing is exactly what most
people will do I just have I've just
been teaching a workshop where I've
given people 12 weeks to finish a draft
that they've been working on for a long
time and the dropout rate is enormous
and this is exactly what you said this
is perfectionism and this is not
allowing yourself the ability to fail
and it's a huge mistake you have to you
know baseball metaphors get tossed
around a lot in the screenwriting trade
because they kind of fit in a way like
if you're batting 300 you're doing great
but that means you're hitting the ball
once every three times right and and and
and but to go back to this what happens
next idea and how I you know and you
would said you wake up on Monday morning
with your cup of coffee and you've gone
to work and you have no idea what what
needs to happen next in your script was
a story I tell about this almost always
in my classes was from Beal Jews where
there's a scene that a lot of people
love actually it's become like a lot of
people one of their favorite scenes and
the ghost Barbara Barbara Adam Geena
Davis and Alec Baldwin
they died they've driven off a bridge
trying to avoid a dog aren't they good
people they tried to appoint the doggie
and they drove it off a bridge
they've drown and they're trapped in
their house now as ghosts
and they've been given a book about how
to have the handbook for the recently
deceased that they can't make that they
can't figure it out and they want to go
into the afterlife and ask questions
about how to be ghosts and how they're
supposed to live it you know live as
ghosts or die is goes whatever and and
but but what my code my writing partner
Michael McDowell I had done is we'd
trapped them so well in their house we
had no idea how to get them into the
afterlife we had done a very good job of
sticking them there what would what felt
like no exit and we had to come up with
a way for them to get out of the house
and the dynamic between you yet you got
to understand Michael was I'm going to
say harvard-educated if not Harvard some
incredibly prestigious university I I
grew up in a trailer park and barely got
out of high school okay okay there was
there was there was a sometimes it was
usually usually playful but sort of a
status issue between us and and the way
we'd often work is that I would like
vomit out ideas and he would just start
shooting them down and it was always one
word no no no no and we were trying to
come up with a way to get them out of
the house Barbara and Adam the ghosts
get them into the afterlife and I was
coming up with more and more convoluted
ideas about how to get them out of the
down house and I'm sure trying to bring
out my supernatural chops and all that I
knew about you know metaphysics and
blotted Eve law just to get them out of
the house and every idea I came up with
no no no and my ideas kept getting
further and further out and more
convoluted no no no and I finally got
really angry with Michael and I said
Michael what do you want them to do draw
an effing door and I just said it
because I thought it was a stupidest
idea imaginable
and I was so mad ice is that what you
want you want them to draw door and he
just started laughing and I started
laughing we said yes that's exactly what
they should do is draw a door so rather
than these incredibly like his
convoluted supernatural nonsense Adam
found a piece of chalk drew a door drew
a doorknob opened it and went into the
afterlife simple but it took all of that
convoluted stuff to get there and that's
what will happen when you sit down and
you're stuck you will write and write
and write and you won't think you found
it and you'll know you haven't found it
but if you keep at it and you keep
writing they'll finally be that epiphany
moment you'll go oh that's what happens
next and then you will write that and
you will have moved your characters
forward one more step in your story and
then the next what happens next is in
front of your eyes and you move forward
like that and it's sometimes it's
literally moving an inch or less than an
inch at a time
and sometimes it's running sometimes
it's crawling sometimes - what happens
next
happen really quickly and you have a day
where you just go oh my god you know I
just you know I just wrote ten great
pages and all they need is just a little
a little sprucing up and they're there
and some days you will write 10 pages
and you will have maybe a quarter of a
pages usable but you will have moved the
story forward that much and it's it's a
kind of alchemy a kind of a magic of
creation but it's such a beautiful
feeling it's best job in the world
you